hey guys let's talk about confidence
how do you boost your confidence in
school
well first you need to know what
confidence really is
because there's a huge difference
between confidence
and arrogance being arrogant according
to merriam-webster is
exaggerating or disposed to exaggerate
one's
own worth or importance often
by an overbearing manner or showing an
offensive attitude
of superiority yeah you've probably seen
those guys in school right
there's a lot of them and some guys
never grow
out of it now confidence is not
pretending
to be better than other people just to
look cool or
lying about your own abilities just to
impress people
no being self-confident in short means
confidence in oneself and in one's
powers and abilities
if you are confident in yourself then it
means that you
are certain full of conviction of who
you are
and what you can do and here's the
secret to confidence
confidence grows with you as you grow
in life and if you want to boost your
confidence in school
then there are eight things that you
need to know that will help you with it
let's get to it
mistakes make you strong now just very
quick if it's your first time here
please consider subscribing i talk about
everything that's got to do with fitness
grooming style and
life itself like this video now
let's start with the first thing that
you need to know that will help you
boost your confidence
try everything and keep the good
if you want to be more confident in who
you are and what you can do
then you need to know what you are
capable of and while you are young
try all the activities in sports try
everything that you can try
to see what you are really good at and
what you
like you won't know if you don't try
try music swimming rugby football
baseball acting art photography
videography chess
and so forth if you can't do it at
school do it at home or somewhere else
explore what the world can offer you
and then you might realize something
about yourself
that you never knew and here's the thing
confidence will come with it
you won't be great at everything accept
it
accept who you are and what you can do
just because you're not
good at something specific that doesn't
mean
that you somehow have less value as a
human being
we are all different and unique we have
different talents
different abilities we are different and
unique
and that's great because that's how it
should be it would be so boring if we
were all
the same and you need to know that
failure is a regular part of life
and you will fail many times i have
failed
a lot of times more than i can count but
it is the failures that made me stronger
and that
pointed me in the right direction
never let the fear of failure
prevent you or stop you from trying new
things
if you fail so what that's the worst
that can happen you just fail
so what then you can learn from it you
can stand up
you can look at the situation make a new
plan and then try again
here's the truth every time you fall
and get back up that is when your
confidence
grows
you are unique so own it
own those things that you think are not
really great or
that does not really fit in with the
rest of the world
never be ashamed of weaknesses
that is out of your control you see
the moment you accept those kind of
things about you those weaknesses then
immediately you're already content
with who you are for example if you are
quirky or if you're an introvert then
own it
don't be shy about it it's who you are
but here's the thing
own it in a confident way tell people
in a confident way yeah i'm an introvert
so i don't like to talk too much
or yeah i'm quirky and that's why i'm
that's
that's what i like that's just how it is
don't let people define who you are
show them confidently who you are
and then they will see it in you and
then they'll accept it
as well and sometimes the things that
the world says
are weaknesses are not always weaknesses
it's just different and unique and you
can make it extraordinary
be prepared always be prepared
for everything there's one big lesson
that i learned in life opportunities
they never schedule a specific time they
just come and go
but if you're not prepared for it you'll
miss it
john wooden said confidence comes from
being prepared
you gotta get into the habit of being
prepared for academics
social situations and sport
you can't control everything in life
sometimes things are just out of your
control but if you are prepared
if you know what's gonna happen if you
know how you're gonna handle it then it
gives you some sort of control
over every situation many people in the
world
lose out on huge opportunities just
because they are not
prepared
dress your best always look your best
for
every type of situation don't overdo it
but at the same time
don't under dress just dress your best
for
the occasion you don't always talk to
everybody
in school right but they still make
assumptions about you
based on how you dress because that's
how people are
even if they've never spoken to you they
see you walking in the things you do
and they make assumptions just based on
your appearance
unfortunately people do judge a book by
its cover
now we know that feeling confident and
good
about who you are comes from within but
you
show your insight to people with your
outside
appearance push
and challenge yourself because that's
the only way that you're going to grow
and learn what you are capable of doing
because you don't know what you don't
know so there are many things that you
are capable of doing
but you just don't know it yet and don't
wait for your parents your brothers or
somebody in your family or your friends
to push you do it yourself you got to
challenge yourself
you got to learn from a young age to
push and challenge yourself to work hard
for the success and the goals that you
want to achieve
in life because here's the thing
only you can walk your own road in life
your own journey no one can do it for
you and you
will reap what you sow today
stop overthinking and just go for it
of course it is good to think and to
plan ahead
but don't overdo it because if you
always overthink things
it can lead to stress anxiety and panic
it usually happens when you think about
things that you cannot
control and when this happens
get into a habit of reminding yourself
all right
i can't control exactly the result of
what is gonna happen
but i'm gonna do my best and then the
result is going to be
the result just as it should be success
does not lie in results but in
efforts being the best is not so
important
but doing your best is all
that matters
turn off the little voice
do you have this voice in your head that
sometimes
says things like you're not good enough
you're not smart enough
or you're not cool enough
turn it off the truth is we all
have this little voice in our heads i
used to have this voice
when i was younger a lot more but even
today sometimes
i get this voice or this doubt in my
head saying um you won't be able to do
this you can't do that
so what you got to do is you got to
learn to turn it off
or you fight back and you say i don't
need to be great in
everything that i do but that's not
going to stop me from trying my best
in everything i do you need to always
remember that the only
limits you have in life are the ones
that you place
on yourself and remember school is not
your whole life
it's just one season in your whole life
and there are many seasons in your life
that you will have to face and you won't
figure everything out
right now it comes over time by
facing the unknown and that that is what
makes life fun and interesting
and worth it and you will always get
your ups and downs
those times when things are hard you
don't know how to handle it
and then there will be days that it's
just great and you wish you could just
pause it and just enjoy the moment
that's how life is always going to be
that's the same but the one thing
that's not gonna stay the same is you
you are gonna change you are gonna learn
how to tackle
new difficult situations you are gonna
grow stronger
as a person don't limit
yourself set your goals and go for it
cheers guys